yeah it's they're pumping out fabricated
nonsense that's totally untethered to
reality and the moment you call these
people out on it
they don't believe in dialogue anyway
they'll they'll slander you they'll
write your name in the bathroom wall
they'll scream at you so the only thing
to do you got to hoax you've got to have
a non-traditional way to deal with
people who are so fundamentally
irrational
i've come to a place where i think right
now in 2017 we're in a strange spot
where that's fascinating the
institutions that used to help us
keep some of this stuff in the lanes
what what is acceptable what's not
acceptable what's right and wrong what's
real and not real whether it's true or
not
that these institutions are crumbling
and by that i mean that media is
crumbling our political institutions
seem to become
an academic institution so that's the
one i really want to get into with you
um all of these things are starting to
crumble it's partly because information
has changed so much i would argue even
worse than crumble but
what you would say they're they're
decimated already
no no i would argue that the academy
certain sections of the academy the
sciences i think are doing very very
well
the humanities are in shambles certain
departments anything tainted by
post-modernism particularly gender
studies the conceptual opinions okay so
let's pause for that yeah okay let's
just go to the conceptual penis as a
social conscience as a social construct
right you wrote
a hoax paper with james lindsey right
and you got this published that we
thought was extremely funny
i mean i read it it's it's
jaw-droppingly ridiculous yeah and it
argued for climate change uh being
responsible for the conceptual penis
yeah and i thought it was really funny
he was a satire sort of the main
takeaway of it is that the penis is not
really a real thing it's just this sort
of amorphous idea and we threw in a lot
of moral jargon we threw in a lot we
appealed to their moral sensibilities
okay so why pete you're an academic why
would you write a hoax paper why would
you mock the very institutions of which
you are a member because i think that
there are departments in the
universities that are making a mockery
of our institutions so when you said
crumbling i don't think that's
that's not the word i would have used
although it's accurate in a sense but
these people are fabricating not only
their own knowledge bases they're
writing things in journals that they
then cite that becomes knowledge they
have they're manufacturing
ideas that are totally untethered to
reality this is how crazy this is
so
so look i'm gonna explain it i'm gonna
try to explain this you reel me in if
this is unclear okay but this is idea is
so crazy that anybody listening to this
and say that's that can't possibly like
this this can't possibly be true so this
is the idea and then i'm going to give
you you're asking me about belief i'm
going to give you
an analog in theology okay so
what these people do
is that they have
moral intuitions
based upon
marx's thought basically i'll get to
that in a second so what they do
to justify this is they manufacture
their own epistemology their own way to
know that justifies the conclusions that
they have so then they can go out and
become activists now
quick detour yeah one of the
biggest problems facing the left right
now
is anybody who calls out a bad idea
is viewed as somebody on the right
we've got to stop that i know a little
something about you you know a little
something about this yeah a lot about
this so let's give you an analogy in
theology so this guy alvin plantinga
is a christian philosopher
so he has these
beliefs these cl they're actually more
than that their claims about reality and
about jesus being the son of god
so he realizes that there's no evidence
that can take him there excuse me so
what does he do he manufactures his own
epistemology he said well you know we're
going to say that there's this thing
called the god sensor and the god sensor
some people have it and it allows you to
just as i apprehend the color red so too
do i apprehend god so he makes an
epistemology to justify these insane
claims about the nature of reality so
just as he has done that
critical theory is that epistemology
that is used and i can explain that is
complicated i'm afraid we're going to
lose people
we've got a lot of terms we've got to
throw out it's very complicated but what
i would like to attempt to do in this
segment is to link the madness on
campuses right now to the intellectual
engines driving that madness and and the
make no mistake about it
these
departments tainted by postmodernism are
absolutely filled with zealots and
morally motivated
ideologues okay so let's so i'll do a
little catch up so that in case anyone's
missing anything so first let's let's
talk about what is postmodernism i know
i know most people know that but let's
just let's just do a couple definitions
quickly okay so let's do the definition
so
okay so the frankfort frankfurt school
has this idea
of well let's even go back for it let's
go back to karl marx karl marx was a
philosopher oh here's a bonus question
why did hitler hate karl marx
i feel like there's a good punchline is
he well it's not a joke it's actually
true because he's a jew anything that
jews touched were oh okay
but other poisonous either they're a
great guy no no no um
uh okay so
so
mark's marxist economics and these
people aren't marxist they're more
marxian would be a better term marx
economics looks at the world in terms of
economical oppression there are
oppressor classes etcetera
so
they have
and then we'll get to the idea
postmodernism very it's simple and
complicated
so they've taken this idea
of
these marxian notions of oppressor
classes and looked at them in terms of
gender and race and and for example the
patriarchy and then they have
hierarchically prioritized people within
that list so the patriarchy is white
heterosexual cisgendered which is a
thing males
and they want it you're at the top of
this
[ __ ] i am absolutely tall and
but that's the other thing they do just
like religion they have their own
defense mechanisms and that's what they
say well you can't criticize it because
you're a cisgendered white heterosexual
male and and is the the ultimate irony
of this that that
is prejudice that is prejudging
because i because i could then sit here
and go wait a minute okay peter bogosian
a white straight cisgendered male yeah
so we judge you based on your immutable
characteristics okay so this is
indispensable to talk about so
you are using words
based upon normal ordinary definitions
i'll give you examples some more it's
like so when you use racism it's the way
i use it
most people who aren't in haven't been
indoctrinated by gender studies in the
post-modern left it's the idea that you
do not judge people particularly
negatively but you don't make judgments
about people based upon an immutable
characteristic like their skin color
but they've changed that definition to
make it systemic racism they've changed
that definition to put in um
a power vector that a hierarchical power
vector that only flows one way so for
example and this
blacks cannot be racist against whites
so they have snuck it's very sneaky
they've taken a normal word
added a a a moral component to it and
changed the definition of a word it you
know here's some if i may give you some
more examples like um equality equality
is a good thing but they've shifted from
equality to equity now what does equity
mean equity means well we need certain
number of people representative of the
general population 70 african americans
we need to have 17 percent
but the problem is that that
that
they also want to take in to account
historical
discrimination and a kind of reparations
for that so those numbers are even
higher so it's i think it can be
summarized in
ruth bader ginsburg's
quip or joke or whatever it is how many
female supreme court justices do you
think there should be
nine
so it's not just right it's not just
that we want equal representation we
want
more because of past injustices
go ahead because this is
this get we got to talk about
deconstruction we got to talk about
violence we could talk about why
all these things when you understand
them
from this mindset they're all coming
from the same school of thought affected
by critical theory that's why the most
so now let's define critical theory yeah
so critical theory is this idea that
you um
that
traditional
power dynamics and traditional and this
is oversimplified but it's a general
idea from which we can have a starting
point for a conversation yeah
see that's again i thought to myself i'm
going to get 500 emails and i'm just
trying to and it makes me it again it it
makes me self-censor and then i'm like
come on yeah okay but that's real that's
a real i don't want to get lost in that
yeah that is a real thing i mean i find
it for myself i try to talk broadly
about things because i want to
communicate big ideas and hopefully
people will then read some books or
watch some other videos or right follow
some other people on twitter or whatever
and then even if you talk well it will
be well you see he yeah he ripped over
that writer he didn't know this why
didn't he talk about the frankfurt
school like we didn't mention horkheimer
once or adorno or all these guys or that
guys
and you know just you just get to a
point where
all of that stuff is centering
essentially it's just it's not
it it diminishes the message it's not
good for you it's not good for
conversations it's not good for
okay so anyway that's why i mentioned
the thinkquisition
and i think that was i heard that that
was the inquisition right now if you
think for yourself and you are not
afraid to buck the trend yeah they will
come to get you it's exactly what you're
talking about so critical theory
so
it's the idea that um
the it's basically a marxist idea it's
the idea that there are these entrenched
power structures and entrenched
power dynamics and one of the things
that we need to do is we need to
recognize these and then we need to
overthrow we need to deconstruct these
traditional hierarchies to make society
more that's the thing more equitable
more firmer what did it what is it it's
complicated
so
these kids protesting at evergreen or
have they don't just x nihilo just get
this idea that they're just gonna it
just
no they get this
these are coming out of specific
departments
in the university and when they're asked
you know why do you do this so what is
this they talk well my professor said
this and then this is the the insane
part that gets back to the conceptual
penis again
that these people have their own lines
of literature
that is these these are intellectual
cesspools they have that's going to get
worse
yeah no so they have to tag intelligence
yeah
that they
have manufactured
what they think that's why they have to
like with cultural appropriation they
have to import ideas like power because
it isn't
the whole thing is made up it's
completely fabricated because they want
to use they want to overthrow these
traditional hierarchies so these kids
get this idea from their professors who
then get promoted in tenure because they
publish in journals and their stuff is
almost never cited by anybody
but yet that's how you rise up and then
what happens is you have a whole canon
of knowledge and you go out and teach
people
and and then you have diversity training
and the the shame of this whole thing is
that there is legitimacy to white power
there is legitimacy to some of this
stuff but the way that it's
metastasized almost
doesn't allow any kind of liberation it
does almost the exact opposite of what
they want to do because it gets you
people like trump but one more thing i
would say yeah but but then what happens
is it goes to colleges of education and
then they start teaching i think i told
you my son has in his geography he has
geography
um
civics i can't remember i'm looking at
stuff he doesn't they've never even
opened a map they've never opened a map
they've never in civic class how many
supreme court justices legislative
branch none of that stuff but he knows
everything about the black panthers but
he knows everything about the civil
rights the civil rights movement is
extremely important
wonderful stuff
but it should no we need to look i'm
looking at we need kids need to know
what country is above canada anyway all
of this stuff gets back to certain
departments in the university that are
pumping out nonsense that are
indoctrinating people and exactly like a
religion they have their own defensive
structures they're
you know being offended is the new thing
uh inclusion is another word that
they've changed the meaning of
so
there is a direct line between is this
tell me is this clear so far i'm with
you it's clear to me yeah okay so
there's a judge with the audience okay
so because if it's not clear something
needs to be unpacked so they want to
overthrow these traditional hierarchies
and they've manufactured their own base
of scholarship to do so so
that's why it's worse than crumbling
because at least if something crumbles
something worse didn't take its place
like if in a lot like it's like having
an alarm clock that rings randomly so
it's worse than just having an alarm
clock that doesn't work
it's there pumping out fabricated
nonsense that's totally untethered to
reality and the moment you call these
people out on it
they don't believe in dialogue in any
way they'll they'll slander you they'll
write your name in the bathroom wall
they'll scream at you so the only thing
to do you got to hoax them you you've
got to have a non-traditional way to
deal with people who are so
fundamentally irrational
that they're not going to have a
conversation and that led you to writing
this
hoax yeah and turning this thing on its
head i thought the best way to start
this thing i don't like to look at my
notes up front but you had a line on
your patreon page that i thought summed
up the whole damn thing pretty perfectly
your patreon bio says
creating journalism that defends science
and free speech
you've come to the right show
all right i think so yeah okay
should we talk about sex first should we
just start with sex and then because
it's all gonna it all bleeds into one
thing definitely yeah um okay uh you
started as a neuroscientist
but you were sort of more
attracted for lack of a better word to
to studying sex tell me about that yeah
so i mean i decided to go back to school
and do my phd in neuroscience and along
the way i had the chance to do a
placement in sexology so i'd never heard
of sex research before i had no idea
what it was but it was so fascinating to
me and i thought it's crazy that we have
the technology to look at people's
brains and look at sexual arousal in the
brain and it tells us so much about what
it means to be human so from from there
i was hooked i loved it my phd
was in using brain imaging to look at
paraphilias which are atypical sexual
interests
and hypersexuality in men
and i love research i always will but i
made the decision to
leave academia
and work full-time as a journalist now
because the climate had changed so much
even between when i started my phd and
when i finished yeah and that's why the
stuff that you're talking about really
is that the nexus of everything that i'm
doing here because now you're on the
journalist side but it's because of the
hostility that you were facing on the
academic side so what were what is it
that you were unearthing or studying
that was
so triggering to people
well within sexology you can't really
study anything that isn't triggering i'd
say across the board someone's going to
get mad at you no matter what but uh
even though you're really looking at
facts you're looking or you're looking
to find facts yeah exactly and even with
brain imaging i mean that's that's
definitely it's a growing feel the
technology is legitimate but no matter
what i think because sex is still
considered very taboo people will either
project their own ideas and beliefs and
values onto it or they just don't see
the value and they think why is the
government funding this i feel really
lucky being in canada we do have a
pretty amazing
scene in terms of sex research
and my colleagues do manage to get
funding so i think that's excellent but
my decision to leave academia
in the last two years i noticed things
were starting to go a bit weird and in
terms of the climate and
in terms of mainstream media i was
seeing
piece after piece about transgender kids
and how young children were socially
transitioning getting on blockers
pubert pubertal blockers and the media
was basically saying this is the
greatest thing this is something that we
should rejoice about that these kids are
so much better off after but from a
scientific perspective the research
actually shows that the majority of kids
who are gender dysphoric actually
outgrow their feelings they're more
likely to grow up to be gay in adulthood
not transgender and so it makes sense
for them to wait not for them to
socially transition at a young age so i
wanted to write a mainstream piece about
this
and there's been a very long standing
history between trans activists and
sex researchers a very ugly history of
activists going after sex researchers if
they don't like what someone study says
or what they say publicly
so i thought about it for a long time i
wrote the piece and i sat on it probably
for about six months and i wasn't sure
if i wanted to put it out
i asked a bunch of my colleagues and
mentors and they all said you know what
the science is
solid but you know you know what's going
to happen if you do put this out and at
the time i wanted to stay in academia
and i said should i wait till i get
tenure
and everyone told me even if you have
tenure nowadays it's not going to
protect you you can still lose your job
so i decided eventually i couldn't stay
quiet and i thought i'm not going to
stay in an environment where i can't
speak the truth and i can't even pursue
questions that are meaningful anymore
because i have to worry about who's
going to get mad and then i'm going to
lose my money my funding and i'm going
to lose my job so that piece went out uh
it was called why transgender kids
should wait to transition and then i
haven't looked back since yeah so i
re-read i've read the piece before but i
reread it this morning thank you you got
here
and
there there's a lot here so
how much of this is just is just
blatantly a misunderstanding of science
like i think there's partly
that you have a misunderstanding of
science and then you just have activists
who just want you to bow to them all the
time are you able to
sort of quantify how much of the
backlash is each
i think to be charitable i try to look
at the other side and give them you know
credit and try to you know think that
they have good intentions
maybe people i mean it's pretty
consistent all 11 studies ever done on
the topic of desistance so this
phenomenon i talked about where kids
grow out of their feelings of gender
dysphoria all of them say the same thing
so the final statistic is about 60 to 90
percent so this is the vast majority of
kids
you can't really question those data
so i think what it could be is people i
mean trans people have a history of
having to deal with medical gatekeeping
of people telling them they don't really
what they feel isn't real i do think
gender dysphoria is a real phenomenon
and i do think we should have empathy
for people who are suffering um so i
think it could be coming from that of
that place of well we don't want people
saying that this isn't a legitimate
thing or that trans people should be
forced to not feel the way they do but
in terms of you know these children
we should be thinking about the best
outcome so it doesn't make sense for
them to transition if that's not
actually going to help them in the long
term i i try to give people the benefit
of the doubt but i do think the
activists they
on some level i think they know that
they can bully sex researchers because
of that history they know that there's
only so much an academic can do
and they've won a couple battles so i
think that's part of it as well how
shocking was it to you when you were
discussing this with colleagues
that they were kind of hinting you may
want to wait on this thing i mean did
you think that you'd be in that
situation and i'm i'm wondering
did any of them sit on some other things
because they were afraid too
it was eye-opening yeah
but i kind of knew
one
one i guess instance i can talk about is
one colleague michael bailey at
northwestern university he wrote a book
that upset transgender activists
and they went off after him ruthlessly i
mean they really tried to destroy his
life and thankfully you know he's he's
still considered one of the foremost
experts in sexology internationally but
i would say that you know i've written
about him previously
i think he's kind of been the poster boy
as to why people are really terrified to
say anything that goes against a trans
narrative yeah so i think you've already
hinted at this and i know your work
otherwise but so you have no issue with
trans people as people just to be clear
this is purely about the science related
to transitioning and hormone blockers
and things of that nature of a certain
age where they're doing it as young as i
think you're writing about 14 right oh
younger than that now well yeah i mean
if there's parental consent definitely
and i have to say for transgender adults
and i'd say even kids who reach puberty
and still feel that way i think
transitioning is is totally up to you if
that's what the path you decide to go
then power to you i don't think there's
anyone any it's anyone's business to
tell you what to do at that point so why
are there basic parameters related to
age then
well there are in terms of i don't work
with children i don't do clinical work
anymore but
in terms of the research literature
usually
clinicians will wait until puberty and
see how the child feels at that time
when the body starts changing when they
start having crushes on their peers and
that kind of thing and the research does
show that
when kids start to you know have crushes
and start dating
and that can play a role in terms of how
they feel about their bodies and whether
they do outgrow it
but just at that point your whole body
is in flux your mental state's influx
your physical state's influx and as you
said what did you say a percentage on
that of how many of them turn out to
just they have 60 to 90 so yeah
so they so 60 to 90 of the the children
undergoing these feelings turn out to be
gay
and then i assume the ones that don't
transition probably most of them end up
being okay with being gay i would
imagine roughly yeah and i would say
even like i grew up in the gay community
i have a lot of gay male friends and
they've said to me when i was young i
told my parents all the time i hated
being a boy and i wanted to be a girl
and i am a girl and why can't i become a
girl and now as a gay man i'm so
comfortable i'm so happy
and they say to me you know i'm kind of
glad i'm not growing up in this time
because i think i probably would have
transitioned yeah well that's why the
external pressure seems so crazy to me
because you just don't know at that at
that age and even if you do know waiting
a little bit isn't gonna for the science
to flesh out it's not that's not gonna
kill you it's just hard talking about
this even you know yeah i mean the thing
is what people also aren't talking about
is that for these kids in some cases the
parents don't want a gay child and this
is what upsets me the most so if you
have a little boy who's very feminine
he's likely going to grow up to be a gay
man but if you
take that same liboy and allow him to
transition to female when he grows up
he's going to appear to be a straight
woman and so these parents are being
lauded as progressive when really
they're homophobic oh god how perverse
that is
that's interesting what you just said
about a certain amount of gay men that
grow up you know they wanted to be or
felt more like a girl or whatever and
then eventually go out and we were okay
because i never
felt that like i played sports and i
played video games and transformers all
the all the things that my friends did i
never felt like i was a girl or more
effeminate people always say to me that
i don't seem gay and i'm always like i
don't know what that you know what i
mean like
i'm married to a guy yeah i mean that's
pretty gay but i never had that but that
that's sort of just interesting about
the psychology
of gay people in general there are gay
people that grow up feeling very
effeminate and there are gay men that
grow up not feeling that way and i'm
sure there's women that grow up feeling
very
butch or whatever and there's women that
grow up that are
you know lipstick lesbians and the whole
thing
have you done any research on it on any
of that uh in terms of my research no
but in terms of what studies have shown
it is about hormone levels in utero so
testosterone if you are exposed to
higher levels of testosterone in utero
you're more likely to be male typical
and masculine when you're born so
whether you're male or female so most
boys are exposed to high levels of
testosterone so that explains when
they're born why they are interested in
male typical toys and activities
um so for gay men
they were likely exposed to lower levels
of testosterone which is why they're
more feminine and the same with with
girls if they're exposed to higher
levels of testosterone they're more
likely to be masculine and lesbian right
even though there's obvious outliers oh
yeah this is on average on average yeah
all right so let's talk about the
natural sciences versus the social
sciences first for the layman what is
the difference they both have science in
a gad come on
right so
the late the lay person will often use
these sort of simplifying heuristics to
determine what is science versus not if
you're wearing a lab coat if you have a
peachy dish right if you have a couple
of chemical formulas that's science
because so the average lay person that's
impenetrable
on the other hand most people have for
example a folk psychology they have an
innate sense of what psychology is and
therefore to the extent that they feel
that they could contribute even though
they might be lay people somehow that's
less impenetrable to them right so they
then will create this false dichotomy
where chemistry and physics that's real
science but sociology you know it's for
people who couldn't hack it in in
physics the reality is that the only
difference is what are the phenomena
that you're studying across these two
general rubrics of science
in the social sciences you're studying
psychology anthropology uh economics
sociology it could be as rigorous as the
natural sciences so let me give you an
example if you could if you're a
sociologist you could study
sociometry which is you know for example
how does power diffuse within a network
and you could use very fancy mathematics
graph theory to try to understand this
so the type of mathematical modeling
that you would use to study how power
diffuses within a network is actually a
very uh fancy mathematical approach but
sociology has somehow been co-opted by
the activists right yeah and so we then
view it as being less scientific but
sciences simply means
adhering truthfully to the scientific
method i posit a hypothesis i think
about the data that i would need to
collect that would either falsify or not
hypothesis i collect that data i apply
some sort of statistical analysis some
mathematical analysis to analyze the
data and then i go one way or the other
that could be just as applied if it's in
economics or if it isn't physics so it
is wrong because i often get letters and
emails from people asking me well
psychology really a science i mean of
course it's a science i mean
ultimately what is more laudable than
studying the most important organism
that we know called humans right so so
it's not as though
by the sheer nature of what physicists
study
they are real scientists but the
sociologist is not and by the way i'm
not trying to defend sociologists here
because i often i'm the one who's
criticizing sociologists but usually i'm
criticizing them for
deviating from the scientific method
what makes them less scientists is that
they become activists and not scientists
but you could be just as much as a
scientist if you study something in
business or if you study something in
chemistry yeah it's interesting that you
say talk about activists not scientists
because that's what i've been saying
about journalists these people are not
doing true journalism and fact-finding
anymore and reporting
based on evidence what they're doing is
letting their own biases
slam right into the middle of this thing
and so for so
one of the things that
uh
i will say differentiates the science
the natural sciences from the social
sciences and that's very much at the
heart of the work that i do the natural
sciences have organized trees of
knowledge so in physics
people agree on a set of core knowledge
that at this point has become
unassailable notwithstanding the fact
that they still have the epistemic
ability to say oh if new provision it's
only provisional if something now
falsifies it i'm willing to revise it
right but there is but the bedrock the
bedrock is there there's core knowledge
that is now unassailable in physics and
chemistry there aren't chemists who are
for the periodic table and chemistry
against it right right therefore you
could build coherent trees of knowledge
or the term that i love to use which was
reintroduced into the common lexicon by
e.o wilson the evolutionary biologist at
harvard is conciliance unity of
knowledge so the natural sciences by the
by the nature of how they test theories
have these organized trees of knowledge
that's what's lacking the social
sciences and the reason it's lacking is
not because the social sciences are any
less scientific it's because it is
easier for ideologies to creep into the
social sciences right so if i'm a
libertarian or a marxist i might study
economics in a way that is very polluted
by my personal ideology so it's not that
the social sciences are
epistemologically and inherently less
scientific than chemistry it's that
biases are easier to creep in yeah it's
funny because i'll hear and i talk to
sometimes someone's a leftist economist
or a libertarian economist or whatever
it is i always think it's kind of funny
like we all have our own beliefs
economically i'm a little more
libertarian these days but if you're
studying something within the window of
the way you want it to be
it's by default is going to be a little
screwy absolutely and as i said it is
naturally more difficult for your
personal ideological biases to come into
something that you're studying in
organic chemistry although i should
mention that there have been famous
cases where even hard sciences have been
deeply polluted by ideologies so
lysenko-ism lysenko was a a
russian or soviet union
geneticist who proposed a theory of
genetics
that
he thought was more in line with marxist
philosophy
that was a wrong theory of genetics that
led to uh massive famine uh and to the
death of millions of people so even it's
not as though hard scientists are
uh inoculated from the possibility of
being parasitized by some of these
ideological biases do you think it's too
late for the hard sciences to be
protected like is it too late for them
to turn their force field on because we
do see this creeping now in biology i
mean brett weinstein's been talking
about this now that now it's really
reaching its hand into that which could
have horrific repercussions well listen
when uh when a scientist in the 21st
century i'm speaking of myself right now
has to appear in front of the canadian
senate to argue that there is such a
thing as male and female and that
evolutionary biology is based on the
recognition that there is sexual
dimorphism and human sexual dimorphism
is a fancy term for saying basically
that they are
evolved sex differences humans
men males are bigger than females right
that's a sexual dimorphism so the fact
that i have to appear in front of the
canadian senate to actually argue these
things demonstrates how far the snake
has gone into the den yeah so in a weird
way your position as a evolutionary
biologist is a is sort of right at the
front of the type of person
that this ideology would attack right
just to cry i'm an evolution
psychologist psychologist
i just said biologists sorry although i
apply evolutionary biological principles
sorry uh yeah i mean it's craziness
right and
and the reason why i'm so if you like
aware of
the epistemological dichotomy between
the natural and social sciences is
because my scientific career of 20-plus
years has really been straddling both
these fields right i apply evolutionary
biology to study consumer behavior
consumer behavior would be construed as
something within the social sciences
evolutionary biology is something that
is within the natural sciences so i
really am very much steeped in both
cultures
and i see the extent to which it is
easier for people to succumb to their
personal biases and the social sciences
let me just give you one example
if you start off with the premise that
you can't agree on whether there is such
a thing as innate sex differences or not
how could you from that starting point
ever build a tree of knowledge that's
organized if at this most fundamental
level we can't agree that there is such
a thing as male or female then we're
done we're cooked
physicists don't suffer from that
problem and that's why they make much
better progress than than social
scientists do so as someone that studies
marketing and why we behave
how we do what turns us on what turns us
off all of that in a weird way you were
you were prepared for everything that
was going to happen politically right
now and what's happening on the academic
front because all of these things
they're all marketing in a way trump
it's marketing hillary marketers herself
in a in a certain way so the trends were
all there life is marketing yeah so when
people ask me so what what do you study
as as a professor of marketing and i
always answer them everything you do in
life is marketing you market yourself on
the mating market we even use the
euphemisms of the marketplace right you
you position yourself in the marketplace
you market yourself in the labor market
you market yourself to friends you
position yourselves depending on whether
you wish to belong to a group or not
animals communicate with each other
right when animals advertise for example
in the peacock the peacock is literally
engaging in conspicuous advertising so
everything in life is marketing so
one of the reasons why i was very much
interested in applying all of my
training in marketing is because that's
i think where all the sexy stuff is
right we take all of these principles
from psychology from economics from
biology uh and then i apply them in
areas that are of greatest import to
most people is there something kind of
scary about that though that it's not
that the best ideas will necessarily win
it's that the best marketed ideas will
win and those often are not the same
things
very good point listen i'm right now
working on my next book and i just
connected with a uh what appears to be a
wonderful literary agent and he actually
made this exact point he said look
what's really important as we move
forward with your book is how to market
it because there'll be people who will
be very resistant to
the ideas that you propose in that book
so again everything is marketing so
basically if you want to so did trump do
you think have not to bring everything
back to him but he must have had i guess
as a businessman and putting his name
all over these things for the last 30
years he had an innate understanding of
exactly what you're talking about
absolutely well listen i could speak to
one thing that he knew very well he
could completely read that many people
the silent majority or certainly a
sizable minority if we're going to use
the popular vulnerability right
were fed up with political correctness
and said i'm going to be the anti-pc guy
and he bet pretty much everything on
that and it turns out that
people responded to it right he could
have equivocated he could have been more
careful with his words but he sort of he
flies off the handle because he realized
that the general atmosphere was most
people whether they're having chats on
facebook or at their workplace by the
water cooler at the university are tired
of feeling stifled are tired of feeling
scared of the next syllable that they
might misutter that might ruin their
careers and he said i am the anti-pc
warrior and
people responded to that marketing
position yeah it's very clear you don't
enjoy telling the story i don't think
you're looking at yours at yourself as
you're some kind of hero or something
you just did what you felt was right but
it is interesting because that's 20
that's 30 years ago at this point and
over the last 30 years you've
done a lot of things that have
been to fight real racism and you have a
track record of it and i think it's
important because these days when we tar
and feather everybody we seem to throw
out everything they've ever done and try
to catch him on one word they said wrong
or one sentence out of context or any of
that so i'm glad we we got that out so
now let's get to the to the present sure
uh okay so
evergreen has done something called a
day of absence for years now it sounds
like it's since the 1970s uh can you
tell me what the day of absence is
because that's what got us to where we
are now so at evergreen it's a yearly
event and it's predicated on
a douglas turner award he's a black
playwright a play that he wrote i think
in 1965 and the central
conceit of the play is that
the underappreciated black population of
a southern town decides to
emphasize to the white population
its value by not showing up one day and
although i haven't seen the play
performed i've read a good bit of it and
chaos erupts because the black
population is so central to the
functioning of the town
the play i think is typically put on
with black actors in white face which is
interesting too
so anyway evergreen decided uh not too
long after its founding
that i think it was originally black
faculty it's now people of color more
generally but black faculty
decided that the black population of
evergreen should ceremonially absent
themselves to make the same point that
the play makes and this has gone on uh
until
i arrived and continued up until this
year
um this year so something changed this
year so let's
and that's where this all begins so what
what changed this year so basically you
had no you had no problem with that i
had no problem with it happening i don't
find anything wrong with it i have one
concern about it which is that a college
is not a town and so when the black
population of evergreen or later the
people of color don't show up the
college does not grind to a halt so i
have a concern that it doesn't quite
make the point that it's supposed to
make but i have no problem with the
desire to make that point and i have no
desire with people deciding to um to
to absent themselves that's all right so
you have so what could be an academic
concern if there was supposed to be a
test that day or some some other thing
but not a concern about the specifics of
the premise of what these people are
right i find nothing wrong with it okay
and this has gone on as you said since
the 70s you've been part of this for a
long time no problem what changed this
year so this year the organizers
i understand now from reading the school
paper that the organizers in response to
trump's election decided to
reverse the order of things so the
organizers are people of color at least
overwhelmingly the school paper reports
them as simply people of color
they decided to reverse the order and
have white people not show up to campus
and i thought about that when i first
heard it i thought i must have
misunderstood what was being said
it's possible that my reaction
is different than it might be because
i'm jewish and
alarm bells go off when i'm told i'm not
supposed to be somewhere
but in any case
i thought i had misheard it and i put it
aside and then there were several emails
so it was announced at a faculty meeting
and then there were several emails
inviting people to commit to participate
but no clarification that that was the
structure yeah and then was it an ask or
a tell
because i think that's let's be very
careful about this yeah there was no
implication that white people would not
be allowed on campus okay there was
however the implication at when this
finally was described the implication
was that white allies
would be off campus and therefore there
was the implication that if you were
white and you showed up on campus that
you were therefore not an ally and that
is the thing
that um pushed me to respond
i did not like the implication that by
by the very act of being there i was not
aligning with people of color that is
that is not my understanding right okay
so there's there's this meeting this is
discussed you then wan realize that
what you had sort of feared was
happening here was happening here you
then wrote a letter now we're going to
put the letter up but i want you just to
paraphrase it i was going to have you
read the whole thing but i think that
that maybe a bit much but we'll we'll
also post links to it down below and
it's out there on twitter and everywhere
else
can you give me the the thrust of what
your letter who was your letter to yeah
and what was the thrust of the letter i
sent the letter to the all faculty and
staff distribution list which does
contain a fair number of students i
think there are a few hundred students
who have a staff position of some kind
or other and so are on the list
um so i sent it to that list knowing
that it would go to those people
not expecting it to be public but i was
very clear and i think i wrote very
carefully and what i said was that
there is all the difference in the world
between a population absenting
themselves from a shared space and a
population telling another population to
go away
and my point was
that
speech has to be free on a college
campus and that everybody has to be free
to be there
i thought that the point was so clear
that it couldn't really be missed
and i was shocked at how
far off the mark the response was
yeah there was an overwhelming reaction
in public
saying
that i was effectively attacking people
of color
privately there was a good bit of
support but this has now become a
pattern on our campus where
especially surrounding any issue that at
least nominally has an a pro equity side
that there is and under there's a
nuanced understanding that can only be
discussed soda voce and then there is
the public response which uh embraces
this one side giving the impression of
consensus but only if you're the person
that people are quietly approaching do
you know that there is no consensus
there's wide disagreement right okay so
there's a couple of things we should
just clean up there so to be clear they
were not telling specifically white
students that they couldn't come but as
you said it would have the idea of then
a white student showing up
you know affect this white student would
have been seen as the enemy it's
possible they wouldn't be even known
they would have shown up to campus and
been seen as a a bad guy or a racist or
a bigot or a white supremacist or any of
that stuff that's number one but you
mentioned that when it got public so you
said that the letter went to the
it went to all staff all staff and
faculty
and there are some
students on that and that's how it got
to the college paper correct yeah the
college paper picked up on it from there
i do want to say that the question of
whether or not it was
or how okay it was for white people to
be on campus was accidentally tested
during the event so when the day of
absence arrived
a friend of mine a faculty member
actually somebody who's been with the
college almost since its founding um
greek woman
misunderstood the intention and she
thought that the intention was for the
opening ceremony of the day of absence
to include people from all races which
would make sense to me
and that then
people would go off campus and there
were 200 spaces in an off-campus venue
for particular events but those 200
spaces were not the limit of white
people leaving campus
so anyway my friend went with her
students to the opening ceremony of the
day of absence
uh and it was held in the longhouse
which is an indigenous structure that
we're very proud of rightly on our
campus
and um
she went in and
apparently was approached by one of the
organizers of day of absence and told
that while she could decide to stay that
really this event was not for people of
her skin tone
and
she decided on that basis to leave and
as she left apparently um an indigenous
woman who is affiliated with the
longhouse
in dismay apparently turned to her and
said the longhouse is a place of welcome
dismayed that she was being turned away
and then she talked to her students the
faculty member talked to her students
and they had felt very uncomfortable the
way they were being looked at so
there is nothing
there is no requirement that any
particular person be any particular
place but there was extreme coercion
yeah i'm glad you mentioned the other
indigenous person there that says that
this is a place of welcoming because
there is a sense
amongst those of us that talk about
what's happening on college campuses
right now that the inmates run the
asylum and unfortunately we know that
the loudest and we're going to show some
videos of some of the people that the
loudest people get the most attention
then it seems like it's everyone but a
lot of it also is just a culture now of
fear
where someone like this there's probably
many other people like this but they're
just afraid to say no no we know we know
you're an ally we know you're not a
racist
or whatever it is you you are welcome
here to show solidarity with us well
there is a tremendous amount of
structure inside the larger
uh
the larger coalition of people of color
so within that there's there are
relationships that are not transparent
to the outside and every so often one
gets a glimpse and so there is a tension
between i think
a very
aggressive vision
on the one side and a much more
traditional vision of equity on the
other but the tension is not visible and
because it's not visible there's this
sense that um that this is a two-sided
issue yeah okay so we're gonna we're
gonna show two videos here because there
really are there are two reactions well
there's several reactions happening here
at once but in terms of what's happening
on campus there's the student reaction
and the academic reaction
and they're sort of connected but they
also come from very different places so
we're going to start with a student
reaction this is you i think you're
standing outside your office and they
and they no this is outside my classroom
this is your classroom okay yeah the
students uh
came to my classroom and started
chanting when i had divided my class up
to have several discussions and one of
my students in one of those discussions
alerted me that there were people
outside the door chanting uh hey hey ho
ho brett weinstein's got to go
that doesn't happen every day so
[Laughter]
so i walked out to them they opened the
door they clearly knew exactly who i was
yeah and i said what's up
and they
told me i should resign and i said would
you like to talk about this and they
said yes and i said okay let's go to the
fourth floor i got students on one two
and three they said no then we're going
to one two and three i came into the
building disrupted really the whole
building not just my class
and then they um
confronted me with several of my
students right there uh in front of the
classroom that we were we were assigned
for that day okay so let's leave it
right there we're gonna play the video
and just to be clear this was the first
moment that you realized this thing had
escalated right absolutely okay all
right so let's let's play this one
no it is debate means you are trying to
win dialectic means you are using
disagreement to discover what is true i
am not interested in debate i am
interested only in dialectic which does
mean i listen to you and you listen to
me
you want
i am talking about terms that serve the
truth those are the topics
[Applause]
i do not believe that students of color
are targeted in the sciences here why
but maybe i misunderstand what you mean
by targeted by racism oh my god
so wait a
second
to me targeted means something different
than what i just heard you define it
i do not believe that anybody on our
faculty with intent especially targets
exactly
i didn't hear you at the beginning
of day of action your presence
[Music]
day of absence has been here longer than
i have i have never protested it until
the idea
until
would you like to hear the answer or not
[Applause]
get the [ __ ] out
do you understand
history could pivot this hallway right
now
oh
[Applause]
history could pivot in the direction of
the values that you are standing here
for yeah resign what resign
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
okay so
there's more of that video again we'll
put the link to that down below as well
if people want to watch the full piece
um i guess the first part would be
you were
you woke up that morning put on your
clothes as you normally do probably had
a cup of coffee went to work well you
could see how by how i was dressed that
i was not expecting end up on youtube so
you're right you're teaching in in
shorts okay i biked in that way okay
your bike to work in shorts i mean you
were just having a regular day you had
you had sent an email
there was beyond i mean i welcome
everyone to read this thing it should be
very clear just by listening to you at
this point there is nothing racist in
this email you were actually fighting
racism in this email uh
then this happens just purely what does
that feel like that moment where you
realize
that something has just shifted what
does that actually feel like
uh that's a really interesting question
i will say that the experience
in college all those years ago
prepared me for this in one way
i think i learned
back then that one should not be afraid
to polarize and that in fact
if you're not polarizing you may be too
timid in what you're doing and that the
really important thing to pay attention
to is that you are polarizing in the
correct way that is to say you want the
people
that you respect to line up with you now
i do find something troubling in this
circumstance because there are great
many people who i think in the end if
they actually knew what i do stand for
would be aligned with me and at the
moment they think they're on the other
side because they haven't looked
carefully at the the policy issues in
question but it feels um
surreal and in fact i've the whole the
that
interchange that you saw was very tense
yeah but it got far worse very quickly
by the end of the day it was it was
anarchy on our campus people were
including me were literally being
stalked and hunted and um
it's a very
um
it's a very frightening feeling yeah i
mean you can even tell by your body
languages you touch your head a couple
times like there's almost like a
an exasperation of just like i cannot
believe this is real
sort of and yet
and yet it makes sense that it's real
because this this monster has been
growing for a long time it has and it's
been uh it's been um simmering on our
campus for a full year
so before the day of absence
letter
there has been a
movement afoot to increase equity on our
campus and the problem i don't want to
drag us too far into a discussion of the
particulars but
the definition of equity has never even
been settled on so we haven't there has
been zero opportunity to discuss the
proposals that have been advanced and so
the proposals are very clearly about
equality of outcome which i can't
support because i know my history um and
not about equality of opportunity which
i do support and yet most of the people
involved in the discussion
uh either haven't spotted or haven't
said that they even recognize the
difference joining me today is a
sociologist a physician a professor at
yale university and author of the new
book blueprint the evolutionary origins
of a good society nick kristakis welcome
to the reuben report thank you for
having me dave i am happy to have you
here sir but i'm depressed that i have
to start the show
the way i sort of have to start the show
and i suspect you know how i have to
start the show yeah
so do you want to set it up for me
well i mean i think we do just have to
get this out of the way i know i know i
mean i knew when the book was published
i mean i've been working the book for
nine years and i knew when it was
published that i would have to
revisit those events from 2015 which you
know were just a challenging period of
my life
um thankfully in the past i'm really
glad to have it behind me yeah but i
recognize that so you tell whatever part
of it you want to tell okay so you
are and we're a professor at yelp yes
this is this is in i think the fall of
2015 yes fall of 2015
and your wife erica who's also a
professor uh childhood development she
was an instructor but yes uh she
basically wrote a piece
that said it was a defensive free speech
and it was sort of worked around the
halloween costume idea that you know you
should wear what you want but you can
try to be respectful of people but you
know we shouldn't have some sort of
top-down version where people you know
administrators or professors or telling
students what to wear
you offered her a bit of a defense on
that
and now i'll throw to the clip is that
fair
fair okay let's throw to the clip you
don't need to bend down i'm not bending
what's your name i don't want to i do
not want you to take your own
i do not want i i do not respect you i
don't hear that i'm looking at the smirk
in your face like i'm disgusted okay
i am sick and i'm sick watching them
argue with you after we've been standing
outside literally for at least five to
six hours between you and holloway
between last night to now we've been
arguing with people who are not willing
to be listened to for a long time and
all i see from you is arrogance
and ego
i am sick looking at you i am disgusted
watching alex argue with you you were
not listening you were disgusting
i don't think you understand that and
before i wasn't i before i was not angry
per se i was disappointed maybe i
thought maybe there was room for it
before an apology you've clearly told us
that you do not plan to offer an apology
for your words you left the meeting last
night to go home and then tweet do not
interrupt me to tweet from your twitter
and then the silliman's twitter you
showed no remorse you tried to let your
wife leave that conversation without
having answered for herself that is
disgusting that is sick and now i wasn't
angry before
i was not angry before but now i am
actually angry sir i really do not
interrupt me i was not angry and now i
want your job to be taken from you
i don't want you to have this job i am
disgusted knowing that you work at yale
university where i will get my degree
where i will look back and think i have
to argue with you
don't no no i miss my partner
don't do it don't do it sir do not do it
this is not the day you do not want to
play this game with me to your side of
things you don't want to play this game
with me okay understand that look me in
my face first of all and understand that
you are such a disappointment to this
university to your students to yourself
to the things that you claim to agree
with you are
you want free dialogue you want free
speech this is how it works someone
speaks you listen you do not cut them
off you do not do these these
condescending gestures you do not smirk
you look them in the face and you wait
you wait until it is your turn
okay so before we even dive into that
the second we played the clip you let
out a big exhale
you're just not that interested in this
anymore yeah or it's depressing to look
back both are true it's you know it's um
i was in the courtyard for two hours and
fifteen minutes from four to six fifteen
about an hour of footage has been
released uh from five or six different
vantage points you showed one clip
that's typically not the clip that's
shown
um
so many people put stuff online you can
re you can piece together the whole hour
between five and six for the first hour
that i was out in the courtyard i
listened quietly to the students um
you know there's a lot of stuff that
that young woman said that's just
factually wrong um she's alluding to an
event that occurred the night before at
the africa afro-american cultural house
at yale where there was a huge event
with hundreds of students
um it had been announced at the
beginning that
we would have to leave that event at the
conclusion it was i can't remember the
precise timing but i think it was
scheduled from six to eight
my wife had to teach a class from seven
to nine so she did in the evening so she
told her students she'd be late and we'd
stay from six to eight she did in fact
speak to the crowd
she
had to leave to teach and i we had a
student in the hospital actually that
evening that i was responsible for and
that also was known
so so when she said that we tried to
leave that's not that's false um
you know i think that um
many of the students were swept up in a
kind of a mob fervor i think they
behaved badly
um
they should have known better
i think they were trying to assert power
if i had a tool when i was that age that
could get grownups into trouble right uh
you know probably i would just get doing
it non-stop right no and they have found
a tool and they often are doing it yes
yes and and so but so i think what
distressed me is i think at some point
in the background of that footage that
one of the administrators actually the
author what happened is is a man by the
name of virgil howard
uh had moved from north uh western
university to yale and had assumed a new
position there and he had written an
email he had written a memo while at
northwestern uh admonishing students not
to wear uh offensive costumes and i
should say for the record that many of
the students that many of the costumes
that he or anyone else would find
offensive i too would find defensive
i wouldn't like these costumes i i'm
well aware of the long history of racism
in our society
i'm well aware of the ways in which uh
there's trafficking in certain cultural
tropes that put down other groups i
reject i am of i have a very
pro-immigrant policy i believe system i
i i think that anyone can be an american
i love the idea that we have open
borders you know i mean i have a whole
set of beliefs that are around openness
and welcoming
you're a lefty yeah i am quite a i am a
lefty i'm left of center play i mean i
have some conservative ideas some
libertarian i think of myself as a
classical liberal i think of myself as
very pragmatic in policy-making so i
like i like markets
to address
most allocation of goods but i also am
very concerned about market failures and
then i want government intervention
anyway
so um
so uh so that anyway that man who was a
then had moved to yale and then he took
out of mothballs this email that he had
sent at northwestern five or ten years
earlier
got a bunch of yale administrators to
sign it and then send it off and in it
he had links to approved and
non-approved costumes the very costumes
which were deemed to be offensive
in his email there were links to lots of
those ostensibly offensive costumes
and the students there had been a lot of
conversation at the time
the new york times had a big piece like
the previous month about the growing
use of halloween costume advice at
american colleges so it was in the
zeitgeist this was the third his email
was the third email that had been sent
out telling students giving them advice
so in my wife's class many of the
students in the class and other students
in the college where we the subpart of
yale that we were responsible for
had told her that they felt this was
very infantilizing and they didn't
really need advice on what to wear
and so my wife from a developmental
perspective wrote a response to this
email which itself had been was signed
by 13 administrators it it didn't it was
framed as guidance but it sort of had
the color of law and um
so she wrote a response saying and her
intellectual point was
not
wear whatever you want right her
intellectual point was
do you students at yale in your twenties
early to late teens early 20s
really need older adults to tell you
what to wear provide you guidance you
should think about that and decide
whether you really and apparently many
students
did want such guidance
and so then i was then thereafter
they're all hell broke loose and i was
in that courtyard and did the best i
could yeah
what do you make of the reason we chose
that clip was because there is the other
more famous clip of the girl really
berating you there were many many
that was the one that i think we showed
here and i think that's the most viral
one but i thought that one was
interesting because the angle was a
little different and you could see some
of the other kids and and the you know
either tears or the local horror or all
of these things
when you actually didn't do anything yes
well that's another whole topic i think
that um
i mean many people have analyzed those
events and honestly i don't i don't know
if i have anything to add to those
analyses i think that
the the thing that was very interesting
to me
so so one of the ideas that i've been
thinking about for a long time is this
tension between our individuality and
our groupishness
and we have evolved to
first of all it's a very interesting
idea we've evolved to be individuals so
we humans
have unique identities so we have unique
faces so you can look at a sea of people
and can tell who's who and not only do
we have the ability to signal our
uniqueness we use our faces for that but
we have the cognitive apparatus to
detect that uniqueness so you you can a
lot of brain power you haven't done you
allocate to tell who's who
so this ability to be individuals is
crucial for our ability to function in
groups it's very paradoxical because you
need a capacity to tell who's my
offspring who's my friend who do i
reciprocate kindness to who do i
cooperate with who's my enemy all of
these things
so all of these capacities of
individuality are crucial to our
collective expression
our ability to live together but equally
we um we have this desire to surrender
ourselves to the group to do something
called to de-individuate to form a part
of a collectivity to suppress our
individual desires which also allows us
to work together
but the irony is when you get too much
of that you get mobs you get panics you
get you know uh
all kinds of collective phenomena that
are destructive rather than constructive
so when i was in the the crowd when i
was in that mob i i knew what was
happening i could tell
so one of the things i started doing was
is i started asking people what's your
name
and i was trying to connect to them
person to person saying you know
hi i'm nicholas who are you
so you're a person and i'm a person
you're not a part of this a mob you're a
human being and i'm a human being
and in fact
the one thing that happened that that is
an intellectual idea that's part of this
book that i've been working on for 10
years but that also i made in the heat
of the moment
is in the moment i said to the students
i said
that i believe in our common humanity
i believe that even even though this
person and this person is superficially
different than me
nevertheless we can talk to each other
we we all have life experiences we're
human beings and and it and then if you
if you don't believe that if you don't
believe we have a common humanity which
i see is a wonderful thing yeah well
that's what that's yes yes because i'm
an optimist
i'm an optimist if you don't believe in
our common humanity why are you even
trying to talk to me
and the students jeered yeah they
jittered it's on film they jeered and i
honestly
i think that's one of the most
depressing things that's happened that
i've ever seen actually is that the yale
students in the 21st century
would jeer at what i regard to be
a fundamental
humane wonderful claim about human
beings is that we have a common humanity
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our academia playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell